[Musique]
le hasard et la nécessité
bien souvent quand on me demande
pourquoi j'ai fait ce métier de chef
d'orchestre et bien je réponds en
inspirant de ce titre du célèbre livre
de jacques monod en effet rien et tout
me destinés à cette carrière je suis né
dans une famille mélomane certes où on
écoutait beaucoup de musique
j'ai la chance d'avoir entendu mon père
jouer du piano en amateur les valses de
chopin et de mozart les sonates de
mozart bien sûr quand j'étais enfant
ce qui m'a conduit à démarrer l'étude du
piano à l'âge de 5 ans mais
parallèlement à ça il fallait suivre des
études sérieuses et des études sérieuses
forcément des études scientifiques et
donc pendant très longtemps j'ai eu ce
balancement entre la musique qui était
mon appétit profond et les études
scientifiques qui était j'allais dire
mon devoir
et puis à l'âge de 20 ans il a fallu
décider ou plus exactement l'appétit est
devenu trop fort et j'ai donc choisi
d'embrasser ses études et cette carrière
de chef d'orchestre
alors pourquoi la direction d'orchestre
plutôt que le piano par exemple eh bien
parce que ça correspondait parfaitement
à mon appétit qui est celui de diriger
des gens bien sûr mais dans le sens de
les convaincre
dans le sens de construire un projet
tous ensemble et puis il ya cette
dimension plus intellectuel peut être où
on se s'interroge beaucoup sur
l'esthétique sur l'histoire de la
musique
et puis on a aussi des questions de
management a réglé puisqu'il faut gérer
des personnels en quelque sorte
bref la direction d'orchestre
al'avantage de d'embrasser tout se sait
matières différentes et ça correspondait
très bien un certain éclectisme dont
j'ai besoin pour vivre
alors pour décrire ce parcours de chef
d'orchestre et bien j'ai choisi
d'évoquer devant vous trois dates qui
pour moi sont particulièrement marquante
nous sommes le vendredi 21 janvier 2005
il est 19h30 maestro c'est à vous c'est
le mot que je viens d'entendre de la
part des régisseurs de l'opéra bastille
qui me pousse littéralement dans la
fosse pour y diriger le barbier de
séville dans une mise en scène
formidable de coline serreau parce que
le chef qui devait le faire la
représentation est tombé malade dans les
heures qui ont précédé et on m'a demandé
de faire cet exercice si difficile de
diriger donc cette ce spectacle au pied
levé sans répétition inutile de vous
dire que c'est un moment
particulièrement marquant pour moi très
important bien sûr qui a beaucoup
déterminer la suite de de mon parcours
je connaissais bien sûr la fosse de
l'opéra bastille depuis longtemps
puisque ça faisait cinq ans que j'étais
chef assistant de james conlon qui était
le directeur musical de l'opéra de paris
à l'époque et j avais dit de diriger
d'innombrables répétition mais c'était
la première fois que c'était un
spectacle public
la deuxième date que j'ai envie
d'évoquer devant vous c'est le dimanche
15 septembre 2013
nous ne sommes plus du tout à l'opéra
bastille nous sommes au gymnase du
croisic loire-atlantique et 400
spectateurs sont venus pour entendre les
premières notes d'un orchestre que j'ai
choisi de créer quelques mois auparavant
qui s'appelle la philharmonie des deux
mondes et dont le but est de jouer la
musique du grand répertoire pour le plus
grand nombre avec l'idée que cette
musique que nous aimons tant les uns et
les autres et bien elle appartient à
tous et qu'il faut faire des efforts
pour la porter vers tous cet orchestre
n'aurait pas vu le jour sans l'appui
d'innombrables mécènes et je les en
remercie évidemment et puis la troisième
date que je veux évoquer devant vous et
bien c'est mardi 15 mai 2018
ce jour là trente enfants d'un quartier
dit prioritaire de saint nazaire qui
s'appelle aval x alors prioritaire on
pourrait beaucoup glosé sur ce terme
parce que on a bien conscience que ça
fait longtemps qu'on a oublié d'en faire
notre priorité mais bref je ferme la
parenthèse et ses trente enfants
totalement éloigné de la musique et bien
se voir remettre par nous musiciens de
la philharmonie des deux mondes un
violons un alto un violoncelle ou une
contrebasse avec le but qu'ils
apprennent la musique par la discipline
collective de leurs qu'istres qu'est ce
que nous cherchons avec ce projet est
bien quand on travaille la musique tous
ensemble il y a d'abord le respect des
différences mon voisin n'est pas comme
moi parce que bien souvent ils ne jouent
pas le même instrument où il ne joue pas
tout à fait de la même façon il n'est
pas de la même ethnie
il n'est pas de la même origine sociale
mais malgré tout on est assis l'un à
côté de l'autre et on joue la même
musique
il y a des vertus de solidarité les
enfants qui sont les plus avancés
montrent à ceux qui ont plus de
difficultés
comment eux ont réussi à surmonter les
difficultés techniques
et puis il y a cette chose
extraordinaire de jouer tous ensemble la
même musique
bref de construire un projet commun en
allant tous dans la même direction
et bien cette pour moi alors qu'istres
vue de cette façon là sous ce prisme là
et comme la métaphore d'une société qui
devrait être idéal alors ces trois
points dont j'ai parlé
eh bien mon appétit scientifique qui
n'est pas mort a envie de dire mais on
va faire une figure géométrique avec ces
trois points
et bien sûr la première figure
géométrique qui vient à l'esprit c'est
une droite sur une échelle de temps et
je dirais plutôt une direction et en
l'occurrence vous l'accorderez une
direction d'orchestre bien sûr et je
dirais que cette direction eh bien ça
n'est pas la même chose que le sens
alors je reviens à mes amours
mathématiques et en géométrie dit affine
est bien la direction c'est comme vous
le savez probablement un ensemble de
droites parallèles entre elles qui ont
des propriétés et des caractéristiques
en commun et le sens
et bien c'est très différent c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus précis je
vais donner un exemple très simple si je
vais
de la baule à saint nazaire je vais dans
un certain sens si je vais de saint
nazaire à la baule je vais dans un autre
sens
et pourtant j'ai utilisé la même
direction j'ai emprunté la même
direction
j'utilise cette métaphore cette analogie
pour décrire la façon dont je vois mon
métier de chef d'orchestre
je suis un dirigeant je fais de la
direction d'orchestre
autrement dit c'est en revenant en en
revenant à mon analogie
eh bien je propose un champ de possibles
aux musiciens qui sont face à moi et
c'est eux qui en se saisissant de ces
différents possibles définissent le sens
et dans ce temps sacré cet espace sacré
que nous avons créé les musiciens et moi
eh bien nous avons créé un espace rêvé
un temps rêvé une petite société que je
qualifierais là encore d'idéal alors
j'ai évoqué un peu le sens
et puis j'ai aussi envie de parler des
sens et le premier sens qui vient à
l'esprit évidemment pour un musicien
c'est louis je vais pas développer
exagérément cet aspect là tellement il
paraît évident mais il ya un deuxième
sens que j'ai envie de d'évoquer avec
vous c'est le toucher
on parle du touch et d'un pianiste on
entend bien que le vibrato d'un
violoniste est quelque chose d'important
la façon dont il va faire vibrer la note
qu'il aimait et bien est très dépendante
non seulement de son caractère de ce
qu'il a envie de faire de proposer comme
interprétation mais aussi dépend
beaucoup du style on va pas vibrer de la
même façon dans une symphonie de brahms
par exemple que dans une symphonie de
mozart ou de haydn où on aura
probablement un vibrato plus léger plus
délicat plus classique
oserais je le dire alors se toucher et
bien c'est indécent ce qui me paraît
très important pour un musicien et puis
il ya un troisième sens et dernier sens
que je veux évoquer avec vous c'est la
vue en effet c'est la beauté d'ailleurs
du spectacle vivant
quand on entend
quand on voit par dont un musicien
émettre un son est bien par un phénomène
qu'on appelle psycho acoustique on se
rend compte qu'on l'entend mieux c'est
une bizarrerie de la nature mais elle
est ainsi fait et donc si vous allez à
l'opéra et que vous regardez un chanteur
plus spécialement
eh bien vous vous rendrez compte que
vous l'entendez mieux que son voisin
alors même que les niveaux sonores sur
un plan strictement physiques
rigoureusement physique je dirais et
bien ce serait équivalent donc cette vue
elle est très importante en musique et
bien sûr je ne peux que vous encourager
tous à continuer puisque je n'ose pas
dire que vous n'êtes jamais allé à
continuer à aller entendre la musique en
direct en vrai dans le cadre de
spectacles vivants et puis si on évoque
la vue et bien il y a un sens parallèle
à la vue que je veux absolument
développer un peu c'est le regard et
pourquoi parce que ce regard c'est
l'outil peut être que j'utilise de façon
privilégiée dans mon art de chef
d'orchestre
je crée une connivence avec les
musiciens qui sont en face de moi et
cette connivence
j'ai la faiblesse de le dire elle met
absolument indispensable si je ne décris
pas si je ne construis pas cette espèce
cet espace pardon affectif momentanée eh
bien je ne peux pas exprimer
complètement mon art et j'ai besoin de
cet échange de regards ce qui est fait
de complicité de grande confiance
le musicien me regarde et lui aussi
parce que il a besoin que je le rassure
dans son interprétation que je le
conforte dans la direction qu'il a envie
de prendre dans sa respiration et il a
besoin aussi que je lui dise oui oui
c'est bien là que tu dois partir
bref tout cet échange de regards est
absolument indispensable
donc voilà pour moi c'est 300 ce qui me
paraissent l'essence majeur en tout cas
pour moi du chef d'orchestre alors il y
a quelque chose au delà de tout ça qui
me frappe énormément et qui fait sens
aussi dans l'art de la musique et qui
fait sens à ma vie
j'ai la chance d'avoir développé depuis
quelques années une relation privilégiée
avec des musiciens du kazakhstan et
notamment l' orchestre philharmonique de
la ville d'astana devenu récemment
nursultan et je suis frappé de l'appétit
je dirais gourmand que ces musiciens ont
de jouer la musique de mozart dub et off
de raiden que nous avons prétendu
tellement être notre musique
eh bien non je vais vous le révéler ce
n'est pas notre musique c'est la musique
universelle et le monde entier veut
jouer mozart et rien que cela devrait
nous rendre plein de gratitude et de
reconnaissance envers le genre humain
alors cette cette musique qui
transparaît transperce les frontières
qui va au delà des cultures qui va au
delà des origines et bien créé une sorte
de société des nations idéal et je dois
dire que c'est une chance de pouvoir
travailler dans cette dans ce domaine là
alors je voudrais conclure aujourd'hui
en citant une nouvelle date
nous sommes le samedi 12 janvier 2019 au
théâtre jean bart à saint nazaire et les
30 musiciens de la philharmonie des
quartiers dont vous découvrez certains
sur cette photo eh bien nous ont
rejoints sur scène
les quinze musiciens de l'orchestré de
chambre de la philharmonie des deux
mondes et nous avons joué tous ensemble
une pièce de béla bartok notamment et ce
moment-là reste extraordinairement
marqué pour moi parce que c'était une
immense joie que ces quelques mois de
travail et été je dirais sanctionner ou
magnifié par cet exercice du concert
public
les enfants étaient bien sûr mort de
trac mais est-ce que ça fait pas partie
de l'apprentissage
et je ne suis pas prêt d'oublier le
regard du petit ryan contrebassiste
plein d'admiration vers mathieu son aîné
contrebassiste chevronnés et al'inverse
le regard de ce même mathieu plein de
bienveillance envers ce petit ryan qui a
créé à un moment un espace
extraordinaire et un moment
particulièrement privilégiée dans ma vie
de chef d'orchestre
alors je dirais une chose pour finir je
formerai un voeu il me semble que si
vous nous voulons ensemble créer une
société qui soit plus marquée par des
valeurs de fraternité de solidarité et
bien nous devrions tous jouer de la
musique ensemble
la pratique de l'orchestré fait pour ça
et tous les enfants de toutes les écoles
primaires devraient apprendre la musique
par la discipline collective de leur
caisse trt j'en suis aujourd'hui
convaincu
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]